F: Salut les Mentalos !
Aujourd'hui on va apprendre à interpréter les pensées d'une personne sans la regarder.
Et pour ça je suis avec mon pote Noam.
N: Bonjour !
F: On va parler aujourd'hui de cumberlandisme
N: C'est parti !
F: Et Noam n'y connaît strictement rien en cumberlandisme.
Et vous non plus.
Et c'est tout l'interêt que tu sois là.
C'est-à-dire que je vais expliquer comment on fait les choses,
tu vas pouvoir poser toutes les questions que tu veux en fait.
N: Ok
F: Les questions un peu naïves...euh...
N: Que les gens pourraient se poser.
F: Exactement !
Tu vois, tu es un peu le délégué de classe !
N: Le délégué, votez pour moi les enfants.
F: Qu'est-ce que le cumberlandisme ?
Le cumberlandisme, c'est le muscle reading. C'est la lecture micro-musculaire.
L'interprétation des micro-mouvements musculaires.
N: J'imite hein !
F: Tu vas faire tout ce que je fais au fur et à mesure !
*Rires*
N: C'est mieux deux que un.
F: Tu vois, en général ça se prend ici au poignet parce que il y a beaucoup de muscles, de petites terminaisons nerveuses,
de choses qui sont reliées jusqu'aux doigts etc.
Dis toi qu'ils sont eux aussi chez eux là derrière en train de faire "ah putaaaaain" !
N: Prenez votre main s'il vous plaît !
F: Oui mais là vous vous demandez : à quoi ça sert ?
C'est une très bonne question qu'ils se sont posés.
Je les ai entendus à travers.
N: Je vous ai entendus
Moi aussi je vous ai entendus !
F: Alors ça sert à faire des choses un peu ouf.
Par exemple, dans une vidéo récemment avec Noam,
j'ai trouvé un objet auquel il pensait grâce à cette méthode.
Je vous invite tout de suite à cliquer sur la tête de Noam !
N: Je fais le carré.
F: Allez voir la vidéo sur sa chaîne,
et comme ça vous allez voir une application direct de ça.
Ensuite vous allez pas pouvoir vous empêchez de regarder 2-3 vidéos de lui,
et elles sont cools donc vous allez vous abonnez.
Une fois que tout ça c'est fait, vous revenez ici et on continue.
N: Il est trop gentil, trop gentil.
F: Bah je suis surtout payé pour ça !
N: Exactement, exactement !
F: Je serais rémunérer un café.
*Rires*
Si je veux faire une étude un peu comportementale...
euh...pour voir s'il ment ou pas,
avec l'intonation de la voix je vais lui poser des questions de base.
Comment tu t'appelles ?
N: Noam.
F: T'habites où ?
N: En Suisse.
F: En Suisse, voilà !
Et t'as commencé ta chaîne Youtube depuis combien de temps ?
N: Officiellement depuis...décembre.
F: Voilà.
Et là on a vu plein de choses sur son visage,
alors qu'on sait qu'il disait la vérité.
On a vu comment tu fais.
On sait que quand tu cherches une réponse ton regard va vers le haut.
On sait que quand t'es un petit peu stressé t'es capable de faire ça.
Donc ça ne serait pas des signes du mensonge, je le sais car je t'ai posé des questions de vérité,
Je t'ai calibré et ensuite ça me permettra de voir des différences.
N: De voir si je mens ou pas après.
F: Exactement.
N: Ok.
F: Et bien pour le cumberlandisme c'est pareil, je vais d’abord prendre le poignet de la personne.
Et je vais avant de poser quelques questions que ce soit sentir un petit  peu les mouvements de base qui y a en fait,
Et en bougeant comme ça voir ce qui se passe.
N: Pour savoir mon oui et mon non d'intérieur en fait
F: Mouai c'est ça qu'elles sont les choses qui ne sont pas à interpréter.
C'est à dire que là, toi, tu as souvent ce muscle là qui bouge pour rien
Donc si en faisant quelques choses et qu'il bouge, ça serait pas un signe de validation en fait.
N: D'accord ok
F: Ça ne voudra pas dire qu'il se passe quelque chose.
Mais, vous aussi, vous avez déjà calibré quelqu'un,
toi aussi tu as déjà calibrer quelqu'un dans ton entourage
sans déterminer forcément que tu faisais ça.
Mais, il y a des personnes que tu connais, tu sais exactement la manière qu'ils ont de parler, tu sais, exactement, la manière dont ils font les choses
de réagir à des choses
donc c'est comme si tu les avais calibré
N: Oui c'est vrai
F: Ça t'as fait que, un jour en fonction de ce qu' ils ne disent pas, toi tu sais ce qu'ils voudraient dire ou tu sais si ils mentent par exemple.
N: C'est vrai, c'est vrai en plus
F: Tu vois
Moi j'ai un pote, à chaque fois, qu'il ment, il se touche l'oreille. Mais vraiment c'est un... c'est ce qu'on appelle un tell au poker
C'est un vrai signe.
N: Ouais
F: Le fait de savoir ça sur lui c'est une calibration
N: Bien sûr
F: Si vous aussi vous avez déjà calibré des gens comme vos parents, vos amis, etc... dites le dans les commentaires. Dites les signes qu'il y a, chez eux, qui sont révélateur
ça sera toujours marrant aussi pour nous de les lire
N: Ouais. Ton papa qui lève les sourcils quand il ment
F: J'ai des exercices pour vous, pour vous entraîner à le faire. Parce que le cumberlandisme il y a pas 30 000 méthodes à part essayer, s'entraîner, ressentir soi même.
2 manières de prendre le poignet de la personne.
Soit la personne nous prend le poignet
et là vous allez surtout réagir sur la résistance que ça offre
Soit vous prenez le poignet de la personne, comme j'ai fait dans la vidéo
c'est ce qu'il y a de plus efficace.
N: Exactement
F: Alors soit on prends comme ça, soit on prends comme ça
quand vous commencez mettez les 4 doigts en dessous,
et on sent beaucoup mieux
N: C'est plus sensible?
F: 1er exercice. Exercice très simple
Vous mettez 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 objets sur une table.
Vous demandez à une personne de penser à un des objets
de l'écrire sur un papier pour vérifier après qu'elle puisse pas changer etc...
et là vous prenez la main et vous y aller en fait sur la table
et vous allez sentir plusieurs choses
Vous allez sentir une résistance, en fait, à certains endroits
et vous allez sentir aussi les petits muscles qui se mettent à bouger
mais concentrez vous sur la résistance
Pour que ces réactions existent, il faut que la personne est quelques choses à faire de mentalement.
c'est ce qui va déclencher la réaction
donc vous pouvez par exemple lui dire de crier "Stop" dans sa tête à chaque fois que vous passez au dessus de l'objet
tu vois?
N: Ok
F: Le fait qu'elle se dise "Stop" mentalement
ça va créer des petites tensions comme ça
et ça va créer une petite résistance
Là, 2ème exercice qui est un peu plus complexe mais qui est hyper intéressant aussi
vous pouvez le faire en 2 étapes,
C'est: Tu donnes un objet à quelqu'un il doit le cacher dans la pièce.
ok, toi tu sors de la pièce, il le cache et après tu dois le retrouver comme ça.
N: Ok
F: Donc tu... tu prends le poignet de la personne et puis de la même manière
N: Tu fais comme les aveugles
F: Exactement, alors au départ le vrai truc à faire pour cet exercice
c'est au départ tu fais faire un tour sur lui même à la personne
N: Pour savoir le secteur dans lequel on va chercher
F: Exactement pour essayer de commencer à diriger
et après tu y va
Tu peux le faire en 2 temps.
Pas obliger de partir sur un petit objet au départ.
Au contraire, au départ, la 1ère fois partait sur des gros objets, des choses un peu dur à cacher.
comme ça, ça va limiter aussi un peu le champs de recherche
N: Bien sûr
F: Si je te donne une gomme et si je te donne une boule de bowling, tu vois ce que je veux dire il y a plus ou moins
N: Là, trouver un pin's là dedans, pas facile
F: Ouais c'est ça.
Voilà ce que j'avais à dire sur le cumberlandisme, jeune homme.
N: Très intéressant, en tout cas, c'est très bluffant.
Vous verrez, en tout cas, c'est assez frustrant, surtout si vous regardez The Mentalist
et tout ça
même si lui même le dit, on sait pas du tout ce que ça veut dire être Mentaliste
F: On ne sait pas, on ne sait pas
N: Donc aller voir c'est vraiment impressionnant
Je vous le dis franchement, c'était fort en émotion
F: Parce que pour lui, ça c'est passé il y a quelques minutes à peine. Voilà
N: Voilà, pour vous dire, on regarde le temps ça fait 10 minutes
F: C'est ça
N: Voilà exactement
F: Un petit rajout avant de partir, j'ai oublié de parler de ça
pensez toujours à bien préparer votre sujet avant de le faire
sinon c'est un risque d'échec.
Préparer le sujet ça veut dire... parler avec lui au départ, le détendre, qu'il se sente pas... stresser
qu'il se sente pas la pression à faire ça
et habituer le à subvocaliser
Subvocaliser, c'est parler dans sa tête
Il faut qu'il se dise "Stop" par exemple quand vous êtes à l'objet ou droite/gauche/haut/bas
mais il faut quand même qu'il se parle à lui même intérieurement, c'est ce qui va envoyer des micros-mouvements incontrôlés
N: Exactement
F: C'est juste ça. C'était important de le re-préciser
Préparer le sujet
N: Préparer le sujet
F: Tu te souviens, je t'ai massé avant
N: Ouais exactement, j'ai bien senti les tensions et tout dans le dos
F: Ouais...
F: Ça c'est très gênant
N: Très gênant
F: C'était tes gémissements qui me gênait
N: Très très gênant les gens, très gênant
*rires*
F: Si vous voulez voir les gémissements demandez dans les commentaires. On vous les mettra... par écrit forcément
N: Par écrit, par écrit
F: Que par écrit
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regarder cette vidéo, j'espère que ce sujet là vous aura plu
Si vous voulez aller un petit peu plus loin, il y a un livre qui s'appelle 'La magie du corps' de John Fisher
c'est un livre qui est assez vieux, c'est à dire 1987.
Je vous mettrai un lien, si je trouve un lien, dans les commentaires.
mais sinon je vous mettrai au moins la référence
Ça c'est pour ceux qui veulent aller plus loin.
Mais n'oubliez pas le cumberlandisme, la seul méthode réelle pour bien l'apprendre et le maitriser
C'est d'essayer de le pratiquer et de se tromper au départ et c'est pas grave c'est tout à fait normal
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas à nous le faire savoir en laissant, comme ça, un petit mouvement incontrôlé, incontrôlable
Un Pouce en L'air
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir et rendez vous demain à 17h
Tchao !
N: Bye